[Music]
the Halloween spirit is in the air at
downtown Summerlin the Halloween parade
of Mischief is back and here to give us
the ghostly details is Haley harzinski
with Downtown Summerlin welcome back to
the show thank you thrilled to be here
it's excited that parade is back what
can we expect the downtown Summerlin we
are so excited the third annual Downtown
Summerlin parade of Mischief we just
added three brand new floats a cast of
80 local kids and so they just caused
Mayhem in the streets and it's so fun
what time does the parade start every
Friday and Saturday in October along
Park Center Drive at 7 pm but if you go
to downtown Summerlin during the day I'm
seeing this the scary statues the place
is decked out right now absolutely we
have 12 foot skeletons throughout the
property which is flying ghostly ghouls
it's just really fun over there and tell
me more about the floats what kind of
floats do we have so we added three
brand new floats we have a pumpkin float
a ghostly graveyard float and so it's
just really great we just try to keep
adding and building to it every year and
then of course you have the you have the
parade but you also have there's
Downtown Summerlin all kinds of shopping
so I soak in the parade what should I do
after the parade you know we really
encourage people to make a night of it
go have dinner with your family or
friends do a little bit of shopping you
can buy some Halloween decor some fun
fall accessories for your house and just
make a whole day of it now when it comes
to watching the parade is it is it kid
friendly you can bring the whole face
we're spooky but we're not spooky
absolutely completely kid friendly we
recommend you get there early get your
favorite spot on the street and just
enjoy we'll have the cast come out here
and perform in a second but where did
you find the kids to perform in the
parade so we work with best and seeing
we do local
operates throughout the year right so we
have the Halloween and then the
Christmas season ones coming up next
correct it's such a great thing when
actually when Halloween comes around you
guys handing out candy or anything like
that at downtown I think they're early
the characters are handing out some
candy every every weekend uh every
weekend at the parade correct and then
at the end of this month we'll have
Halloweentown which is going to be a fun
festival at the lawn oh I love it and
two and the great thing about Halloween
is you wear your costume one just
Halloween but you encourage kids to come
dressed up on the weekends right of
course we encourage everybody to come
down you know really celebrate Halloween
all month long who doesn't want to do
that and so you can bring your Littles
down have them in costume and just have
them enjoy the whole fun I love it so
how will we get more information is our
website or anything correct you can
visit summerlin.com and we'll have all
the information again 7 P.M every Friday
and Saturday awesome well if we have the
dancers we have a little performance
here why don't you guys come on in Haley
you know we'll step to the side and you
guys can take it away do your thing you
look amazing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
awesome job